[Music]
welcome back to CBS mornings We are
continuing our coverage of the
indictment of former president Donald
Trump now you know the exact charges
have yet to be announced but we do know
they're in connection with money paid to
adult film star that's Stormy Daniels
ahead of the 2016 election Donald Trump
is vowing to fight these charges and
he's got the support of many many
prominent Republicans for some political
reaction to this we're joined by
Democratic Senator Elizabeth Warren good
morning to you Senator good morning it's
nice to have you at the table again
as we've been saying all morning
unprecedented Uncharted Territory
unprecedented motions
what was your reaction when you heard
that no one is above the law not even a
former president of the United States
you know that's a very sober time for
our country of a real moment in history
and yet I think the most important part
of this is to say that a foundational
piece of our democracy is holding that
it is possible to have an independent
investigation to go wherever the facts
lead and then to follow the process
through and that's going to mean to
follow it all the way through including
assuming there is an arrest if there's a
trial Donald Trump complete not guilty
he can bring whatever evidence he wants
consider we know this in school we're
always taught no one is above the law
why are no Republicans saying this we
hear Lindsey Graham saying this is legal
Voodoo political persecution political
hatred that this is all about a
political Witch Hunt why are there no
Republicans not one saying that no one
is above the law that this is all about
politics I it's hard not to see it it's
hard not to see a political lens on this
is it not I can't answer for the
Republicans I can only answer for myself
and for myself it's about backing off
and letting the system work trust in the
process there is no reason to believe
there's been anything other than an
independent investigation it's walk
through all the steps it is a grand jury
according to the evidence released that
has voted independently and we will go
forward with that process and that
process offers plenty of opportunity for
Donald Trump or anyone else accused of a
crime to bring forward whatever evidence
they want to use whatever part of the
legal system they want but we follow the
law for everyone because it's
foundational in our democracy and I
remember sitting in class Foundation
everybody gets treated this is the thing
that's so concerning Donald Trump is
calling for in his words death and
destruction he's calling for his allies
to Rally behind him he's asking people
to please speak up please show out are
you worried about violence industry
dangerous rhetoric yeah it's very I'm
very concerned about that it is
dangerous and violence is never the
answer this is part of the reason we
have a court system so that we don't
resolve these things are you worried
about it are you worried about it I
always worry about violence thoughts but
again I think that's why it's important
for as many people as possible to take a
deep breath to be calm to step back and
say this is one more step in the legal
process Donald Trump is going to have
plenty of opportunities to make his case
an open court and the prosecution will
have the same opportunity let the
process go forward no one is above the
law
so Senator let me get your thoughts on
some other other issues that are
bubbling under the surface here many
Americans are still worried about the
banking system right now uh what do you
want to see happen so that we don't see
another bank collapse not perhaps now
but in the future exactly the right
question what's the go forward but to
get the go forward right you got to take
just a little Look Backwards so remember
big Bank crash in 2008 nearly brought
down the worldwide economy we put in
place very strong banking laws to make
sure that doesn't happen again and it
didn't but those multi-billion dollar
Banks they didn't like it so they came
to Washington including the CEO of
Silicon Valley Bank starting in 2016
they start lobbying weaken the
regulations weaken the regulations on us
Donald Trump ran for president telling
those multi-billion dollar banks that if
he got elected he would weaken the
regulations
he got elected and he put in
anti-regulators in those spots he then
went to Congress and said weaken the
laws that demand tougher regulations and
Congress with the help from both parties
opened that door then Jerome Powell head
of the FED used that and mowed down
literally dozens of regulations but
Senator even when there are regulations
in place the San Francisco fed did call
attention to what was going on at
Silicon Valley Bank and nothing was done
so the question is with the regulations
that are in place should there be some
teeth should there be some
accountability so you are exactly right
it takes Regulators who keep their eye
on the ball and the problem we've got is
starting with that change in legislation
in 2018
Regulators took their eye off the ball
Jerome Powell head of the FED encouraged
them to do that right does he now have
to do a bit of an about face he needs to
do a 180 degree about face having been
the guy who mowed down the regulations
he now needs to be the guy because he's
the one in this job to start standing
those regulations back you have
confidence in the banking system I hear
a lot of people saying I'm going to take
my money and put in a shoebox and go
home the show look for most depositors
there's protection they shouldn't have
to worry about this but overall back to
your question we need to make sure that
we have a banking system that we can
rely on over the long Arc right and that
the federal government is not called in
effectively to backstop these Banks the
only way we're going to make that happen
is if we make banking boring again I
have a bill right now
with Senator Josh Hawley uh Senator
Braun Senator Cortez masto bipartisan
bipartisan and what it says is you're
the CEO of the big Bank you give
yourself a bunch of big bonuses and
stock options and then blow your bank up
because you took on the risks you're
going to have to give all that back
right the the Federal Government Can
claw that back the idea here is if
you're thinking about making big money
yeah don't go into banking right go
somewhere else right Senator we want to
get your thoughts on a topic that we've
covered quite a bit here on the show and
that's the Banning of tick tock now some
Progressive lawmakers have said that
this wouldn't actually address the issue
of data privacy have you seen evidence
of tick tock being a threat to our
national security so I'll look at this a
little differently I think the question
of privacy of our data through social
media through just tracking us on our
phones is something that we should be
very concerned about but it's not enough
just to say this is a tick tock only
problem it's a problem all the way
across in terms of the data that are
being collected okay so are we casting a
wide enough I want that we are not
casting a wide enough debt I want to see
a wider net on the privacy issues I also
think on the question of China because
it is different with China here but
China has other they've got apps out
there they've got social media they've
got other pieces
not be banned so the way I see it is if
we're going to look into the question of
data privacy and we should I've got some
very serious concerns about this we need
to cast a broad enough net we cannot
pretend
that if we can focus in on one company
that we're all done and have fixed this
can you give a short answer to a
question about guns once again the
horrible shooting in Nashville I know
it's not an easy answer but will
something change this time are your
Republican colleagues saying something
differently behind the scenes about
let's make changes in gun laws I just
can't tell you how frustrating this is
our children die
because there are republicans in
Congress who continue to insist that we
can't put just basic safety measures and
so we don't see any behind the scenes
conversation it makes you optimistic or
hopeful can I just do one in
Massachusetts we have tougher gun laws
if the laws that we have in
Massachusetts were the laws all across
this country independent studies show we
would reduce deaths from gun violence by
about 70 percent these are the lives of
our children our neighbors our friends
and we just can't get through that's why
it's frustrating people know what to do
exactly nothing ever changes we'll
probably be having this conversation
again
Warren thank you so much thank you for
having me